hey what's up everybody at Santa Mac and
welcome to the second installment of our
week's best anime video series now the
purpose of this series is to help you
guys catch up on any awesome anime
videos that you might have missed the
week before and just remember that the
links told the videos that we mentioned
are right there in the description and
also if you have a recommendation for
next week just leave it in the comments
last Sunday ki cook made a video in
which he claims that the source material
is irrelevant when it comes to anime
adaptations what he essentially does in
this video is he critiques those fans
who try to make excuses for bad anime
adaptations by saying that well you
can't really judge the anime without
reading the manga first gig Luke is
trying to make the point that each anime
adaptation has to stand on its own
merits now I think it makes a really
good point in this video it's really
hard to judge an anime any anime by its
source material whether that material is
a five hundred chapter manga or a novel
from 200 years ago like The Count of
Monte Cristo which actually inspired gun
kutsuu oh so yeah I had this theme of
adaptations it's something that
interests you definitely check this
video out on tuesday class reflection a
kar khada posted a video on the top 10
most anticipated anime of fall 2016 and
he gives us a really rich list in this
one and he provides some insightful
feedback as to why he thinks that some
of these anime are might turn out really
well now you can really tell the glass
reflection that is homework before
making this video he looks at the
directors of the upcoming anime he looks
at the musical composers and then he
looks at their previous work in order to
get an idea what we can expect from the
new anime so yeah definitely if you
haven't heard of this guy's channel
check it out he's really insightful he's
really informative he's funny and he has
some pretty awesome catchphrases let's
jam forneverworld uploaded a video this
week in which he looks at the future of
naruto shippuden and the naruto anime in
general especially now that the big
naruto vs sasuke showdown is complete he
looks at whether we're in for a whole
bunch of filler for the rest of the year
so if you're a big naruto anime fan
definitely check out that video
forneverworld actually uploaded another
video this week in which he asks whether
Dragon Ball super is actually worth
watching for Dragon Ball Z fans so if
you're a fan of Dragon Ball Z who's
still on the fence and you haven't given
draggable super a try definitely look at
that video it will be helpful to you
this week lost paws
uploaded another vlog from his trip to
Japan and this time it featured a visit
to Akihabara the iconic anime
neighborhood and ho TACA cultural hub in
tokyo if you want to see what a real
life anime city looks like definitely
watch this video and you will probably
recognize this neighborhood as the
inspiration for scenes in a whole bunch
of anime mystique or nexia makes our
list for the second week in a row with a
brand new top ten shounen anime
countdown now this new list only
features those animate that were not
already featured on his previous top ten
shounen anime countdowns so it
definitely features some interesting
hidden gems that are not so well known
outside of Japan and for that reason
alone this video is worth the watch on
Saturday Joey the anime man uploaded a
video called do we need anime reviewers
and critics where he talked about the
benefits of actually providing a
critical opinion about a certain anime
even when that opinion might be
controversial and get some pushback from
fans no choice point in this video is
that of course within the anime
community we're going to have
disagreements but it's important to keep
having the conversation to keep talking
to each other even when we disagree
because this keeps the anime community
active and thriving I really have to
agree with joy on this point I think
that it's important that we keep
listening to each other and talking to
each other even when we don't agree
because we can still learn a lot from
each other now having said all that
misty your opinion on clannad is just
wrong man it's wrong on Saturday anime
unity uploaded their latest AMV and
there was a bleach amv called the
rebellion this video has amazing visuals
such great quality and it's absolutely a
must see for Bleach fans and actually
had another MV recommended to me this
week and this MV comes from a youtuber
called fruity RL this is an amv called
final stage and it's a hike you AMV and
it's just top-notch quality you have to
check it out it's brilliant so yeah guys
that's it for this week we hope you
liked this video and if you did please
like share and subscribe and until next
time see a space cowboys